Halle Berry clarifies her comments about
winning an Oscar
of course it meant something you saw me
up there I was speechless in a way and
speaks out about the need for more women
of color in film the more work we have
the but you know the more chances we
have to be there you recently said about
your winning your Oscar in 2001 that it
almost feels like it didn't mean
anything because of the lack of
diversity now do what did you mean well
I feel like it meant something but I I
guess I'm just disappointed that there
has not been another woman you know in
15 years that has stood on that stage
like I did that night and that's just
wildly disappointing to me I hope that
in the next years to come someone else
stands there and that we continue to
evolve and grow and that women of color
can actually start producing and writing
and directing and not just being the
dancing bear but making opportunities
for ourselves
alright go gal gadot because gal gadot
is setting the stage for women of all
races so good for her and good for
Wonderwoman ET spoke with Hallie at a
pop-up screening of her new thriller
kidnap which she's producing and
starring in I'm being a mama bear like
any mother who has children would be no
difference it's a non-stop
edge-of-your-seat heart something
thriller acting producing relaunching
her interactive website hollywood how
does the mama of to balance it all the
last decade I feel like I kind of have
taken a backseat my career and I've been
with my kids I think that's been really
important their childhood is fleeting
and you only get one chance at being
with your children during that time so
I'm kind of back now my son is three
he's about to be a full time schooler
it's sad and exciting at the same time
because that means he's growing and I
wish they would just stay little forever
[Music]
you